♪ ♪
>> Tom: HIDIN' BIDEN IS BACK.
AMERICA IS FACING A LOT OF
PROBLEMS IN THE MEDIA HAS BEEN
CLAMORING FOR JOE TO DO AN
INTERVIEW BUT HE HAS BEEN
PLAYING HARD TO GET.
>> I WANT TO THANK THE PRESS FOR
COMING IN.
SEND YOU BACK OUT IN THE COLD.
THE HALLWAY IS NOT MUCH FURTHER
DOWN.
[REPORTERS SPEAKING AT ONCE]
>> Tom: BIDEN HAS GRANTED
SEVEN ONE-ON-ONE INTERVIEWS WITH
JOURNALISTS THIS YEAR BUT DON'T
WORRY, HE DID SIT DOWN FOR THIS
HARD-HITTING INTERVIEW WITH
TOUGH AS NAILS INTERROGATOR
DREW BARRYMORE.
CHECK OUT THIS GRILLING.
>> THE TRUMAN BALCONY I THINK,
OUTSIDE.
IT LOOKS OVER.
>> IF FLOTUS CHANGE ONE OF YOUR
HABITS, WOULD IT BE.
>> SO MANY.
FOR REAL.
SHE HAS GOT A BACKBONE LIKE A
RAMROD --
ALL SHE DOES.
DON'T WANT TO MESS WITH THIS
WOMAN.
>> Tom: THAT WAS NICE.
I DON'T WANT TO COMPLAIN ABOUT
DREW BARRYMORE.
I'M NOT GOING TO BLAME HER
BECAUSE I THINK SHE IS CHARMING
AND LOVELY AND SHE WAS A CHILD
STAR, LIKE YOU.
DO YOU THINK BIDEN HAS TO DO
MORE TOUGH INTERVIEWS?
JUST LIKE IN THE LAST SEGMENT,
IF THEY ARE NOT HOLING THEM TO
ACCOUNT, WHY NOT JUST KIND OF
COAST ALONG LIKE THIS?
>> Jesse: YOU CAN DO AN
INTERVIEW LIKE THIS IF YOU DO
OTHER HARD-HITTING INTERVIEWS.
THERE IS AN APPEAL, YOU LEARNED
ABOUT THE RELATIONSHIP AND YOU
GET THE SOFTER SIDE.
THAT'S FINE.
EVERYBODY DOES THAT.
IF SHE'S ONLY ONE YOU'RE DOING
IN THE LAST THREE MONTHS, WE ARE
GETTING PLAYED.
HE HAS BEEN PLAYING US AND HE'S
BEEN USING THE TWO EXCUSES, ONE,
I AM OLD.
AND LISTEN.
I AM AN OLD GUY.
I AM BEING PROTECTED BY MY TEAM.
THEY DON'T WANT TO PUT ME OUT
THERE.
I MIGHT SAY SOMETHING AND THEY
MIGHT --
OKAY.
THAT'S BEEN EFFECTIVE.
IT'S BEEN EFFECTIVE DURING THE
CAMPAIGN WHEN HE DID THE COVID
THING.
I CAN'T GO OUT OF MY BASEMENT.
FOR THE FIRST TWO YEARS, HE'S
DONE LESS INTERVIEWS THAN
REAGAN, BUSH, OBAMA, TRUMP,
EVERYBODY.
IT'S BY A COUNTRY MILE.
HE'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO DO
THIS.
WHAT I'M WORRIED ABOUT, SAY IT'S
A DEMOCRAT.
ANYBODY.
GET TEN PSALM 45-YEAR-OLD,
50-YEAR-OLD PRESIDENT GETS IN
THERE WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
AGE AS AN EXCUSE AND HE PLAYS
THE SAME GAME AND HE DOESN'T
TALK TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Tom: THE STRATEGY WORKED
DURING THE CAMPAIGN BECAUSE HE
SPENT IT IN THE BASEMENT AND IT
WORKED FOR HIM.
HE SHOULD KEEP DOING WHAT WORKS.
>> Dana: THE MEDIA AT THE TIME
WAS WHOLLY FOCUSED ON
DONALD TRUMP.
THEY DIDN'T GIVE A LOT OF
COVERAGE TO BIDEN.
THEY TRIED TO COVER BIDEN BUT
THEY WERE REALLY FOCUSED ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND ACTUALLY
STILL ARE TO GREAT EXTENT.
I THINK IF HE WANTS TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT AGAIN, HE'S NOT GIVING
DEMOCRATS A REASON TO WANT TO
SUPPORT HIM.
THE FOX NEWS POLL THAT WE JUST
HAD SAID SOMETHING LIKE I DON'T
KNOW 49% OF PEOPLE SO THEY
WANTED HIM TO RUN AGAIN OVERALL.
FOR DEMOCRATS WAS ONLY 63% OF
DEMOCRATS.
THAT WAS UP FROM ABOUT SIX
MONTHS AGO.
BUT HE'S NOT GIVING THE REASON
TO SAY THAT GUY CAN DO IT AGAIN.
WE SHOULD FULLY GET BEHIND THAT
GUY.
THEY ARE TENTATIVE, WAITING,
SEEING.
AN INTERVIEW WITH
DREW BARRYMORE.
PERFECTLY LOVELY BUT ANOTHER
REASON TO DO AN INTERVIEW IS TO
GIVE YOUR TEAM SOMETHING TO WORK
WITH AND GIVE THEM A LITTLE BIT
OF COVER.
TO ME, THE SPOKESPEOPLE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION ARE FLOUNDERING,
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO THE
BORDER.
THERE'S ONE DECIDER, ONE
COMMANDER IN CHIEF AND THAT
PERSON SHOULD DO AN INTERVIEW OR
A SPEECH WHERE HE CAN EXPLAIN TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHAT HIS
PLAN IS IN THE BORDER.
THAT'S THE NUMBER-ONE ISSUE, AS
WELL AS THE ECONOMY.
ON THE BORDER, EVERYBODY IS
FOCUSED.
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE HE IS AND
SPOKESPEOPLE ARE BLAMING
REPUBLICANS FOR HELPING
SMUGGLERS.
>> Tom: JESSICA, AS A
STRATEGY, WHY DOESN'T BIDEN SIT
DOWN WITH REPORTERS THAT ARE
TOUGH?
MAYBE RIGHT WING REPORTERS.
THE PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT, YOU
KNOW WHAT THEY LIKED, WHEN TRUMP
WENT AT IT WITH THE REPORT
APPEARED WITH LESLIE ON
"60 MINUTES."
RIGHT-WINGERS LOVE TIME.
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT MIGHT LIKE IT
IF JOE MIX IT UP WITH SOME
RIGHT-WINGERS AND DID SOME TOUGH
JOE ACT AND MAYBE BLEW HIS STACK
A COUPLE TIMES.
>> Jessica: HE DOES SUCCEED
WHEN HE'S ON VARNISH, WHEN HE
SAYS THINGS LIKE, YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE IT DOG FACED PONY LIAR OR
WHATEVER HE SAID.
SOLDIER.
AND FRANKLY HE HASN'T TAKEN
APPROPRIATE VICTORY LAP FOR THE
MIDTERMS.
THIS IS THE TIME TO SIT DOWN FOR
AN HOUR LONG INTERVIEW AND TALK
ABOUT WHY DEMOCRATS WERE THE
CHOICE IN THE MIDTERMS THAT
PEOPLE MEAN THAT EVERYONE
PREDICTED THIS RED WAVE.
JESSE WATTERS MOST OF ALL.
IT'S NOT --
A LOT.
THE TRAFALGAR GUY WAS WORSE THAN
YOU.
A >> Jesse: OTHER PEOPLE WERE
WORSE.
I'M NOT GOING TO NAME NAMES.
SENATOR TED CRUZ OR
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
>> Jessica: HE SHOULD DO MORE
BECAUSE HE'S GOOD AT IT AND I
FIND HE'S AT HIS SHARPEST WHEN
HE'S ASKED SHARP QUESTIONS.
IF YOU ASKED, RENDERING
QUESTION, HE CAN GIVE YOU A
MALARKEY ANSWER.
>> Tom: HE NEEDS THE TOUGH
QUESTIONS BUT I THINK HIS WINDOW
MAY BE CLOSING.
MAYBE AFTER THE ELECTION HE
COULD'VE GOTTEN AWAY WITH IT BUT
I THINK DEMOCRATS ARE GUNNING
FOR HIM NOW BECAUSE A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT JOE BIDEN
TO RUN FOR REELECTION.
EVEN THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO
BE TOUGH ON HIM.
AM I RIGHT?
>> Judge Jeanine: I AGREE.
I THINK THAT DURING THE MIDTERMS
WE REALIZE THAT THERE WERE MANY
DEMOCRATS WHO DIDN'T WANT HIM
ANYWHERE NEAR THEM IN RACES.
SOME OF THE MORE CONTESTED AND
CLOSE RACES.
I THINK JOE BIDEN, IF YOU HAVE
THE WHEREWITHAL, WOULD SIT DOWN
WITH A REPORTER AND BE ABLE TO
GO BACK-AND-FORTH ON ISSUES
LIKE, YOUR SECRETARY OF HOMELAND
SECURITY SAYS THE BORDER IS
OPEN.
YOUR VICE PRESIDENT IS IN CHARGE
OF ROOT CAUSES.
HAVE YOU DETERMINE WHAT THEY ARE
YET?
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO ABOUT
CRIME IN THIS COUNTRY?
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT ISSUES
THAT NEED TO BE ANSWERED.
YOU CAN TELL ME THAT THIS GUY IS
FOCUSED ON THIS OR THAT.
I THINK HE IS INEPT.
I THINK ANYONE WHO IS A
PRESIDENT OF I BELIEVE THE
GREATEST COUNTRY ON EARTH SHOULD
HAVE THE ABILITY TO SIT DOWN AND
TALK ABOUT WHAT HE IS DOING.
ANSWER QUESTIONS HONESTLY.
HE IS SURROUNDED BY --
LOOKING TO DO NOTHING BUT COVER.
THE EVIDENCE IS PURE AND SIMPLE
AS WE CAN SEE WITH WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THE FBI, TWITTER, AND THE
WHOLE HUNTER BIDEN THING.
IT'S ABOUT JOE BIDEN ULTIMATELY.
HIS DENIAL AND HIS REFUSAL TO DO
THIS IS A COMMENT ON HIS BELIEF
THAT HE CAN'T